In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading, from the Sinaxadune, for July 25, on which we commemorate the Dormition of
Saint Anna, Mother of the Theltoccos.
On the 25th of the month, we celebrate the Dormition of Saint Anna, the Mother of our most
Holy Sovereign Lady, the Mother of God.
Saint Anna, who became by God's grace the grandmother, according to the flesh, of our Lord Jesus Christ,
was of the tribe of Levi, the last born of the high priest Mathis, and his wife Maria,
who had two other daughters, Maria and Subeya.
The eldest, Maria, married in Bethlehem, and brought Salomey the midwife into the world.
Subeya also married in Bethlehem, and bore Elizabeth the Mother of Saint John the Baptist.
Anna married the wise Joachim in Galilee, and after the intervention of God who put an
end to a long sterility brought Mary, the most holy Mother of God, into the world.
And so Salomey Elizabeth and the Mother of God were first cousins, and according to the
fleshly descent, our Lord was the second cousin of Saint John the Forerunner.
After having given birth to the Mother of God, who had been established by God at the apex
of all human sanctity, the only one pure enough to receive within herself the Savior of
the world, and after having placed her in the temple at the age of three as a pure and
immaculate offering, Saint Anna spent the rest of her life in fasting, prayer, and works
of mercy, awaiting the fulfillment of the divine promises.
She gave her soul into God's hands in peace at the age of 69.
Saint Joachim died at the age of 80, but it is not known which of them died first.
The only thing that the Church's tradition has handed down to us is that the most holy
Mother of God was left orphaned at the age of 11 while she was still in the temple.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God have mercy on us and
save us.